it is incredible naivity to think that a
17-year sentence will set an example for
anybody the only example this judge has
set is that there is a
biased neol neocon unip party machine
that will destroy your life unjustly if
you speak out against them in any way
and of course that's not me defending
what Joe bigs did in tearing down a
barricade yeah and you know going into
the capital or whatever he should not
have done that I imagine Riot charge
would be a couple coup of months or
something maybe followed by probation or
whatever but when you look at the crimes
committed by the farle it is fairly
obvious they're they're they're being
paid money when the far- leftists rioted
in DC and burned and set fire to
buildings and garbage in the street and
a limousine smashing Windows the city
paid them millions of dollars paid them